by far the most controversial thing I
wrote in the book is the notion that
good ideas are bad and being a quasi
academic and somebody who in theory
loves and likes good ideas this
realization dare I say epiphany came as
a bit of a shock to me but the reality
is when you do a hardcore realistic
pragmatic analysis of the economic value
of ideas you realize for most
organizations the overwhelming majority
of ideas they have lose the money
they're not break even good ideas are
bad ideas are the wrong unit of analysis
for thinking about innovation ideas have
a great brand you know somebody says I
have a great idea people pay attention
if you say I have a brilliant hunch
they're going to look at you lucky or
not if they say I have a passionate
belief they're going to look at you like
you're religious zealot ideas have a
great brand and under that brand
umbrella people sort of overweight
someone who says I have a good idea I
think saying that you have a good idea
is saying like well gee it's like it's
like a an art critic saying reviewing
how much the art costs or how much a
sculpture ways ideas are the wrong unit
of analysis why because what happens to
the majority of ideas as we try to March
them towards implementation we come to
the sad realization that G it seemed
like a good idea at the time and so
there's a bit of a survivorship bias you
know the good ideas that survive are
celebrated as a good idea all the
quote-unquote good ideas that died along
the way cost us money along the way
wasted our time a long way wasted our
emotion along the way they're forgotten
and buried good ideas are bad my book is
about the better unit of analysis if you
care about innovation
I think you need to have the rigor and
intellectual self-discipline not to
think in terms of what is a good idea
but what is a testable hypothesis what
is a testable hypothesis and you know
what even that's not good enough that
testable hypothesis has to be simple to
test it has to be easy to test and it
has to be cheap to tests because finding
the Higgs boson is a multi-billion
dollar hypothesis to test most
organizations can't afford to test
multi-billion dollar hypotheses most
organizations don't have the time or the
money let alone the interest on this so
one of the most important takeaways I
encourage people to think about and
rethink about is if you have what you
think is a good idea the best way to get
a return on that investment is to
reframe that good idea as a testable
hypothesis that can be run in a fast
simple cheap business experiment